Have you ever played tic-tac-toe?
The board looks like this,
and you take turns with
another player trying to make
a row of three Xs or Os in a row.
I would play this all the time
with my cousins, because it's so
easy to draw out on a piece of paper.
But it didn't hold our attention for
long.
Most of the time we would tie, and
it would get boring really quickly.
You can imagine if this were a game app,
I wouldn't play it for
long because the pace is too slow and
the game is too predictable.
To really attract and
keep players interested,
you want to make a challenging game.
When I think of a challenging game,
they all have a few things in common.
First, the game starts off slowly so
that it's easy to play and understand.
Second, the game complexity
grows over time.
This is especially important for
monetization,
because complex difficult portions
of your game can be good places to
introduce in-app purchases that can help
players overcome certain challenges.
If you decide to include in-app
purchases like this, keep in mind that
if a game is too challenging without
them, it will detract from the quality
of the game, and it can drive players
away if they feel like they're being
forced to buy helpful items in
order to advance in the game.
So, always keep in mind your players and
their game experience, because a quality
game experience Is the most important
aspect of a challenging game, and
design your in-app purchases to
be helpful, but not required.
A good example of a game that
bounces being challenging, but
not too challenging, is Candy Crush.
Candy Crush has a lot of
levels to progress through.
They start off relatively easy and
introduce you to the rules of the game.
And as you breeze through
the first couple levels,
it gives you some winning momentum.
The levels get more
challenging over time.
Here you can see the difference
between early level of Candy Crush and
a later one that's a special level,
which includes licorice and
bubbles as extra obstacles.
And when you don't quite pass a level
it feels like you were so, so close.
And if you just need a little extra
push, the game will offer you items and
power-ups for
purchase that will give you that push.
And this is a great example of
why it's so important to plan for
monetization early on, so
that you can have good timing and
introduce in-app purchases right when
players might need an extra boost.
But it's hard to know
exactly what challenges or
items your game players
will like the best.
So later in the course, we'll talk about
how to test out different versions of
your game, like different challenges or
levels, to see what works best.